by le aseguro que no puede prometer cuál
va a ser el resultado final en
afganistán o si va a ser sin riesgo a
pérdidas se detalló que es una de las
retiradas aéreas más grandes y más
difíciles en la historia al lado de su
equipo de secretarios en la casa blanca
reafirmó que su misión es sacar a todos
los estadounidenses y afganos aliados y
que pondrá a disposición todos los
recursos para los militares que sean
necesarios bailén afirmó también que
está en comunicación constante con los
talibanes sobre los que dijo eran
enemigos declarados del estado islámico
para que dejen pasar a las personas que
tienen pasaporte estadounidense por los
retenes camino al aeropuerto de kabul
sin embargo el pentágono y periodistas
en terreno han informado que llegará el
aeropuerto de kabul es cada vez más
difícil cerca de 18.000 personas han
sido evacuadas desde julio y en este
momento hay cerca de 6 mil militares
estadounidenses tratando de sacar el
mayor número de estadounidenses y
afganos misión que se complica porque
países aliados en la región como qatar
anunciaron que dejarían de recibir
refugiados de este país